[Music]
beca's search for the one does continue
on The Bachelorette tonight but look
there are so many people that are
skeptical about finding love on reality
yeah it seems like you only hear about
the break-up so you found out the odds
of making it work in the real world
actually pretty good
[Music]
the past three bachelorettes are all
still engaged Rachel and Ryan lived
together a Dallas so Jojo and Jordan
Kaitlyn and Shawn are in Nashville and
even though they've been engaged for
three years they are in any hurry to Wed
no timeline I'm in the next 10 years
overall the Bachelorette is that a
better success rate than the bachelor
six couples are still together
three are married with kids including og
Bachelorette Trista Sutter who has the
longest running relationship of the
entire franchise almost 15 years of
marriage whether you meet on television
or not it's really about making your
relationship a priority as for the men
of The Bachelor in 22 seasons Sean Lowe
is the only one who still with his final
pick at least once a week I'll say can
you believe we met on a TV show because
we lived such a normal life Sean and
Catherine are celebrating four years of
marriage and welcome baby number two in
May two other bachelors did find love on
their seasons including the most recent
re he famously proposed to then dumped
Becca before proposing to runner up war
not every bachelor ending is gonna be a
fairy tale this is this is real back in
season 13 Jason Mesnick also pulled a
switcheroo after the final rose but it
ended up working out for him and
runner-up Molly you've been married
eight years and have a daughter so there
is hope for our
but it seems paradise may actually be
the best place to find love in just four
seasons of the spinoff
four couples have made it work back in
the real world the latest Jared and
Ashley just got engaged in Mexico the
place where it all began your fiance's
and everybody will eventually get to
watch it and see everything on bachelor
in paradise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]